Yanik and aqua and we had posted
something last week about an gawk way
looking forward to free agency and maybe
not wanting to be with the jaguars long
term we've seen a tag and trade dynamic
for pass rushers the past year it was d
ford traded from the Chiefs to the 49ers
and then Frank Clark traded from the
Seahawks to the Chiefs it could be in
Gok way who reportedly now will be
tagged by the jaguars that's really not
a shock we expected that when he could
be traded if he doesn't want to sign a
long-term deal or Kris he just goes year
to year under the franchise tag you know
I'm waiting for more players to say fine
I'll take your 15 16 17 million whatever
it's going to be foreign gawk way I'll
buy an insurance policy to protect me
against a career-ending injury and I'll
I'll play it out I'll play out two more
years and then I'll be a unrestricted
free agent because you won't be able to
tag me a third time because the third
time it's quarterback money yeah well I
mean yes and you're right somebody's
gonna continue to make that type of
gamble or they're gonna make that gamble
at some point but it's just it's risky
but I'm more interested in the fact that
you know Yannick and Gok way says he has
no interest in signing a lot like what
happened down there in Jacksonville you
know I just feel and I always wondered
what this relationship was between
Yannick and Gok way and the Jaguars it
seemed to have gone awry really I want
to say ever since the fight would Dante
Fowler what two training camps ago right
Mike was that you know I just feel like
things have been uneasy there and of
course we had the Jalen Ramsey thing too
so what is it why does Yannick and gaku
a want out of there he is a big-time
pass rusher and will have a market I
mean this is a guy that yes I would say
is is definitely worth more than a guy
like D Ford who I think a lot of you
know he is this is a pure passion pass
rusher with a lot of speed I'm just
surprised he's drawing such a line in
the sand but the Jacksonville Jaguars
are saying he doesn't want to be there
long-term and my interpretation of that
fight with Dante Fowler Jr and is this
is all just based on circumstance I
could understand why andhaka would have
resentment for the guy who was the third
overall pick in the draft got the big
contract and never lived up to it here's
a doc way with thirty seven and a half
sacks in four seasons he had 12 in his
second year with the team and I don't
know if there's any kind of fumes of Tom
coffee
one that are still kind of affecting in
Gok way maybe he crossed that bridge
mentally last year and he can't uncross
it even though Coughlin is gone but he's
been trying to get paid you know when
you dot all the eyes crossed all the t's
check all the boxes show up and do your
job and they don't reward you you get to
a point where you don't want the reward
from them you want it from someone else
and it may very well be that they have
to trade remember when they drafted John
up Josh Allen last year not the
quarterback the the pass rusher we all
kind of thought that maybe they're
planning for a future without Yannick
and Gok way and they can have Allen for
four more years before they get to a
point where they'd have to tag him or
pay him a long-term deal and it could
just be that they're going to get with
the camphor and goth way and move on I
mean if Clarke got a one in a two for
the Seahawks maybe in goth way gets at
least a first rounder for the jacket
yeah I think that's fair I mean he's yes
I do think he's gonna get a first round
he'll get first-round compensation I do
you know again this is a gig a guy that
you look at if you just want to compare
him to like a little bit apples to
apples like to DeMarcus Lawrence his
productions been better than DeMarcus
Lawrence and DeMarcus Lawrence became a
hundred million dollar man last year so
that's the type of contract that I think
he's going to be able to demand on the
open market there's gonna be the the one
thing I know here early on and you know
free agency we got a few weeks man
there's some good pass rushers and
there's some teams who have legitimate
needs at the pass rushing position to
where I think that's gonna really make
that market fun to watch here at this
soft season and to see the money thrown
around to those guys yeah and we know
that that that is a highly valued
position it's quarterback and it's
stopping the quarterback and great pass
rushers can do just that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports